[Music]
as dawn breaks in the babylonian city of
sapar
beltani receives an urgent visit from
her brother
it's 1762 bce during the reign of king
hammurabi
beltani is a naritu a priestess and
businesswoman
promised to the temple at birth at
puberty
she changed her name and gained her
elevated 92 status
in a ceremony where a priest examined
the entrails of a sacrificed animal for
omens
the 92 are an esteemed group drawn from
babylonia's most affluent
families though the rules are different
for naughty two in each city
in sapar they are celibate and never
marry
they live inside the gagum a walled area
inside the temple complex but are free
to come and go
and receive visitors beltani owns
barley fields and a tavern her brother
manages these businesses
while she fulfills her duties as a
priestess
this morning he makes a troubling
accusation
her tavern keeper has been diluting wine
with water
if true this means she's been
undermining the business
beltani relies on to sustain her in old
age
but the consequences would be even
higher for the tavern keeper
the punishment of diluting wine is death
by drowning
the temple court is meeting this
afternoon beltani has just a few short
hours to find out whether there's
any truth to these allegations but she
can't go to the tavern to investigate
taverns are off limits for priestesses
even
priestesses who owned them she could be
burned to death for entering
so she sends for the tavern keeper to
meet her at the temple of shamash
the patron god of sapar the temple is a
stepped pyramid called a ziggurat in the
heart of the city
and visible from 20 miles away it
symbolically connects heaven and earth
and is viewed as the literal home of the
god shamash
who gave humanity the code of laws and
is the judge of the babylonian pantheon
beltani leaves an offering of bread and
sesame oil
in a private room she never enters the
inner chamber of the temple where the
god lives
a place so holy only high priestesses
and kings visit
outside worshipers play music and leave
gifts
which are later collected and used to
feed temple workers
including the naritu the tavern keeper
is waiting with grim
news she says beltani's brother has been
altering the weights used to measure
payments to cheat customers
when the tavern keeper confronted him he
falsely accused her of watering down the
wine
if true beltani's brother is the
dishonest one
and altering weights is another crime
punishable by
death beltani is running out of time to
get to the bottom of this
though she can't go to the tavern she
can check on the barley fields her
brother
manages to see if he's been honest there
in the granary she sees much more grain
than he reported to her
he's been cheating her out of her share
like
all naritu and sapar beltani inherited
the same portion of her father's
property
as her brother these were rare
circumstances for women
in a time and place where property
passed through men
still their families didn't always honor
their rights
although natatu traditionally went into
business with male relatives
the law stated they can choose someone
else if their brothers or uncles
weren't up to the task with the evidence
she needs
she hurries to court a judge presides
over the temple
court along with two naughty two the
overseer of the gagum
and a scribe beltani asks to remove her
brother as her business manager
citing the greenery as evidence that
he's mismanaging her properties
the judge grants her request the scribe
records the new contract in cuneiform
into a wet clay tablet and the matter is
settled
she's protected her income and spared
her brother's life
by withholding the true extent of his
crimes
perhaps it is time to adopt a younger
priestess
someone to take care of her in old age
and inherit her property
who might do a better job of helping
with her business
being a priestess can be a dangerous
business travel to ancient rome where a
vestal virgin is about to be buried
alive
learn more about her role in society and
the mistake that would lead to her doom
with this video
[Music]